Let's talk a bit about perspective camera control. The parameter with the most
obvious effect is the field of view. As mentioned before, this value is the
angle from the bottom of the view frustum to the top. It also adjusts the side
to side angle, factoring in the aspect ratio. The field of view parameter acts
something like a zoom lens. As you set this angle smaller and smaller, whatever
is in the middle of the screen grows larger and larger. For these images, what
I've done is have the field of view match the camera move more or less. In
other words, as I zoom in on the model, I also move farther away so that the
model takes about the same amount of room on the screen. As we zoom out the
perspective distortion gets less and less. At the limit, that is, as we attempt
to go infinitely far away and have the field of view approaching an angle of
zero degrees the view becomes an orthographic projection. If you're practically
infinitely far away, everything you're looking at is at essentially the same
distance, as far as relative size goes. Which is how the orthographic
projection treats this scene. This effect of having the field of view and the
camera movement offset each other, has become a go-to effect in cinematography.
If you want to express something that's weird or dreamlike happening in the
scene you zoom in while moving backwards at the same time, or vice versa. Give
this demo a try yourself and see how it looks.